what's going on you guys can you hear me
fine man am i coming through the mic
fine i'm kind of curious if you guys can
hear me
gotta be able to hear me fine
gotta be able to hear me man do you guys
hear me
come through the mic i am i mean i'm
talking i hope i'm through the mic
i'm as much in this mic as i can be
we can hear you wonderful
so give me about
i'd say
i didn't say i was going to start the
stream until 15 after i got i'm getting
something to drink real quick
and then we're going to start this
stream and uh
if uh
don't expect me to beat this game all
right let me let me be very clear i said
i'd play hold up let let me go
let me go to uh
let me go to the chilling stream real
quick man
let me be very clear
there is some
misconceptions
that's going on in this in this thing on
these twitter streets
you
i don't have to beat the game
let's let's let's make that clear now
attic don't have to beat the game
attic just got to play for a good amount
of time to give you guys a show that's
all
don't don't expect attic to beat this
game now you know like i said you know
we get some good support tonight in the
stream
i might stay a little longer you know
what i'm saying but
like don't expect
perfection
because regardless what you guys need to
see
at the end of the day
i still haven't
played these games
so that's why i'm pointing that out
there so give me like
three four minutes and then we're going
to start this
i am playing this on the switch
because with the nes thing i got the
controller here the the pro controller
so i am playing it on the switch
so
we're not doing no 24 24-hour stream
it's not happening
but we we we we're going to get we're
going to get going on this man we're
going to get going
you know might do a little pre-show
about a 5-10 minute pre-show oh my god
so so we ain't counting saul all right
i appreciate the 20 super chat so but uh
we we uh he said let's go young buck
uh you know
how you guys like the the title man
millennium plays old school ninja gaiden
for the first time i feel like that was
catchy i don't know maybe it's just me i
felt like that was catchy
but maybe it wasn't maybe some of you
don't don't like that you should play it
on the og xbox is it even on the og xbox
i didn't know um saw told me it was on
the switch
so we have it on the switch
so i i don't know if it's on the og xbox
so let let's just go ahead and get
straight into it
let's just get straight into all of this
nonsense that you guys want going on man
so here here is
the nonsense that i got to deal with
[Music]
i so so which one is it which which one
they they
their their nes thing is very weird
someone's gonna have to tell me which
one it is
is it
this one or this one
because why is there two why is there
two see this is why i didn't be dealing
with that old nonsense man look there's
two why is there two
you got to explain that to me not the og
there's the special one which i don't
know why there's a special one and then
there's just like a techno and i mean
the same one
you guys are going to explain that to me
you have to explain
why there's two
one is special do do i play the special
one
okay so i play this one
okay
all right so let let's go let's go you
know i was gonna get something to drink
we'll play a couple couple things before
i get something to drink all right so
does do i sound fine compared to the
audio
because i know that audio loud
hold up hold up let me
let me see something here i don't want
to be too
i don't want that audio being too loud
man do i sound fine
[Music]
all right so
b
is just some regular dash
oh i sound sad you mean being a little
suspect there
empire so this is a jump
so two buttons do the same thing
all right so it looks like is that all
right so you can wall jump
what is this rewind
what
i don't know what that is
[Music]
oh my god
look at this horrible
[Music]
i don't even know what that does
hold up
all right so
a bunch of this nonsense going on okay
hold up
hold up
what you doing man
i don't know what that thing is
but i assume that's something that we
avoid
[Music]
hold up
i don't know what these are
hold up
oh so you can dash hold up
how do i use the ability
i'm not rewinding
i was just i was paying attention to
what they said first off
don't rewind you're cheating
also i guess there's a time limit okay
that's fine we're gonna lose
because it's some wack time limit but
that's okay
all right so i got a little bit of a
feeling of uh all the controls
they got some whack time limit
so we got a time limit we gotta do all
this stuff in all right
i play better under pressure anyway
nintendo
we just gonna skip that because it's
some whack time limit
oh this dude throws stuff at me
i don't know what any of these stuff do
this thing's too much
got to keep going man
got this time limit i got to deal with
what is this dude doing oh
okay i need to stop looking at the chat
you guys are getting me killed
keep in mind if i lose at anything i'm
blaming the chat
so i want you guys to be aware
that i'm always have it out
i'm never gonna admit to anything i'm
always having out
i don't know what this is about
okay
[Music]
[Music]
okay
i don't know is that the whole round is
that the whole stage
was that the whole stage
i really don't care what this dude's
saying
oh
so someone should tell me how how to use
these little power-ups i'm getting ow
what is that
[Music]
oh
oh my god
i'm definitely about to die there's no
denying that
look at how
extra these steps look
[Music]
okay okay that's how you do it
so i'm definitely gonna die this round
there's no denying that
so i see this is a lot about timing
oh i'm dead
so i guess i gotta start the whole thing
over again because that's how
oh i don't
i was prepared to start the whole game
over again
so he's a ninja but he can't climb that
little crevice
[Music]
so it's about a lot about timing
oh died
[Music]
game over
see i don't i don't plan
on beating stuff anything on like any
first go
so i want i want people to be
aware of that i don't like i don't like
this dude
see look
guys wonder why
ain't nobody like these old ass games
they not could have done with that
hold up
see but if there's anything that i'm
good at it's it's i i know what's going
on
oh so
oh my god
see
see it's those little those little dog
things what's what's that about
these little dog things
so i got i got to make sure i climbed
make sure that
the dogs
oh my god
get off of me you
idiot wow
wow
[Music]
the thing's going to be right back too
because that's how this game is yo
got me playing this old ass stuff where
you get glitched up so easy
people like oh the games are so hard
these older games are not they just
they're really cheap let's be let's keep
it a buck they really cheat they hard
see look at that they put that dude
there intentionally to knock me off the
map
got this nonsense going on right now
see i can't turn around on a dime either
all right so
i'm starting to get the timing right
better though
so it's like screen based
yeah
idiot i saw that coming that time
yeah they're definitely cheap you guys
are just bugging
and that's okay man you guys can bug all
you want
wow
it requires timing and
in in memory okay lord metroid
okay
i got you timing and memory i'm gonna
put that in my handy dandy notebook man
make sure
i wish i knew how to like use these
weapons
oh my god
it requires timing
and memory
timing and memory
my name
look at that it requires timing and
memory
up and b which one's b
requires timing and memory
memory and timing
oh look at that man they being
inconsistent with that dude
they was trying to have that dude hit me
[Music]
oh
[Music]
yeah i'm climbing this
all right so i think i jump up here jump
up here jump up here climb this
jump up here
oh
oh what is that
oh my god like
wow
only got like 52 seconds left fam
i assume this is another boss
to my knowledge
this is isn't yeah it's another boss
what's this boss what's this look at
this little ass platform you guys want
me to fight on
yeah i kind of figured he was gonna have
some kind of projectile
open it's a projectile that lives okay
and then there's a football player just
randomly running for no reason okay
all right all right we got this football
player
all right oh and this is it's got a gun
too
gun
look i only got like 20 seconds man
i don't know how much
is he gonna be able to make this jump
oh
wow
wow
that was
that was
that was a little ridiculous i'm gonna
be real with you
they got me very comfortable thinking he
couldn't make that jump and then they
gave and then he randomly got some knees
or something man
randomly got some knees or something
randomly got some knees he should have
been able to make that jump
that was trying to mess with me
yeah come here you
you can get it too you can get it too
okay he got me he got me all right all
right all right we're going we're going
to do this mission oh okay so it's not
over we still got more time
we good we good we good right now we
good right now stage two of two
we get him
we get this little no you ain't doing
that
wow i i that's gonna be that's
that's a that's a rough memory thing
that i have to do right there
oh my god i'm just gonna
i'm just gonna ignore you
okay i'll just
wow you can't just jump down there all
right i see them i see them
well let me just jump down there
wow
clamping on the walls i don't want to
clamp on to
yeah i know you come in that time you
might get me once or twice
ow
and i love how they just come back too
wow
i can't grab onto the ladder
this is annoying
[Music]
saying you can't climb like the moment
you latch on to something it's just a
wrap
i ain't feeling that man i ain't feeling
that
yeah i see you coming
uh-huh
i don't like that like you should be
able to just jump down there i don't
like how you can't just randomly jump
back up
and people say well that's just because
it's skill addict
okay keep telling yourself that
we we wow
i press the button
i don't care what it says there i press
that button
i
there's got to be a better way of
handling that dude i need to actually
sit there and figure out
a good way of handling him
of course i dropped that
do
uh
i don't like this one up here they got
me going on man
yeah i got you
they put that dude there on purpose
they trying to kept me slipping
this dude's gonna get me there ain't
nothing i can do
i don't like that like they put that
dude i guess i gotta wait for him to
face in the other way or something like
that i don't know
up and attack
there's literally
i don't know why you guys keep saying up
and attack up and attack addict damping
attack
i put attack at it
oh you got to be kidding me
wow
this game's on some [ __ ]
i'm so glad to be a 90s baby man i'm so
glad that i was in diapers when this
nonsense was going on
i mess i miss such a fantastic bullet to
miss
you know i want everyone
wow
that's that's cool jay that's cool you
can say i suck that's fine but we'll go
ahead and show you you can have that
that those those conversations man
because i could take criticism can you
it's like the moment this dude attacks
it's just a rap
wow
i don't know how to use these abilities
you guys say
you guys talk about these abilities but
you guys don't bring up these a bit look
at that nonsense man that's what i don't
like i don't like that the game's not
the game's not difficult they just put
in the place just to mess with you
[Music]
see look they put that dude in there
because they know you can't handle both
of them
well at least that worked out
you have to have ninja magic what's
ninja magic
i'm curious what ninja magic is
get this little fire thing
jump down
i knew he was coming back
all right so he looks like he throws
three
oh my god i need to actually
like take my time when i get to that
place
i don't like the random like i don't
like the grabbing that's what i don't
like
they deliberately put this dumb ass
right there
they know what they do
with yeah i'ma just get hit by you and
run by you
i have a really hard time with those
i don't understand these abilities you
guys talk about
do
oh my god
i don't like how unresponsive this stuff
is man
like it feels like sometimes it's so
unresponsive to like move left and right
like how does that make stuff difficult
like
it
when when the game itself is more
challenging than the actual people
that's when you got issues
get out of here
get out of here
wow
i don't understand how do you i've done
what you guys have said about the
ability like eight times
like i'm not getting trolled by you guys
man
addict use your magic ability
first off you're a ninja why do you got
magic abilities
one would think that's like against the
rules
use your magic ability at it
i don't even know what magic ability you
guys are referring to
i don't even know what that timer is
so you know it is what it is
i feel like that's telling me
yeah oh my god
jesus man
this dude with the dagger is my
kryptonite man
yeah
i'm so bad at that timing
you can roll
i don't know if you can roll they don't
tell you anything
and then people go act like that's
adding to the challenge not to tell you
the controls of the game
i ain't feeling that man
telling you not how telling you
not telling you the controls of the game
is not adding to the challenge of the
game
i'mma be real with you like it's not
like look at that man
they put him on this little square
because they know
that he like you get bounced off like
you're a pop figure like you shouldn't
get bounced off that drastically
come on man what are you doing
come on
[Music]
this is this is this is
oh my god
i hate these [ __ ] things man
oh i apologize i'm not supposed to cuss
but
you guys want me to play some
infuriating [ __ ] like this man you're
gonna have to deal with the custom
look at this dude with the gun
and then he regenerates just because
it's off screen
which is is dumb
i'll be so glad to get rid of these old
ass games man
let's get to a point where we don't
bring these up ever
i would love that
let's do that
we don't ever bring these things up ever
that's my dream that's my birthday wish
man
let's get to a point where we
i had a dream that we never
talked about this game
and what are you doing
i gotta like
only got one feature this
wow
yeah i'm getting schooled
have you not seen the the nonsense they
do it in this game you're getting
schooled
they they're deliberately putting people
at the edge of buildings just no wonder
the market crashed with dawn since
experiences like this
getting schooled
see i went from this morning playing
such a fantastic experience like elden
ring to playing this
what am i doing with my life
i'm losing my stuff man i'm losing it
i'm losing it
wow i didn't even press the button that
was on me that was on me the rest was on
the game but that one particularly was
on me
uh that was on me
but i'ma still blame the game i'm gonna
say i read the chat you know because i
can't i can't admit anything's my fault
i'm gonna say i read the chat see look
at that sometimes i can hit both of them
sometimes i can
look at that
why is there football players
look at that
i don't like this dude this dude gets on
my nerves
back up
wow
[Music]
nah i'm saying this crashed the market i
we ain't doing the atari this crashed
the market this game crashed market
everybody in life played this game and
rallies it was so
bad that it crashed the market and i'm
gonna stick to that i'm gonna stick to
that uh that story that's my story every
time we talk about this game i'm gonna
talk about how this game crashed the
market
for good
oh look at that man they knew what they
was doing
oh god what's this what's this
oh so you got it okay
[Music]
so i'm probably not gonna beat this dude
but i can get a little bit more
of how to fight them
[Music]
[Music]
come on man
okay okay
pretty simplistic i'm gonna be real with
you guys
but it's okay it's okay man it's okay
simplistic
what is this bizarre state anyway and
who with that woman
as i grow more and more suspicious i
went off to look for that
suppose acquisition to my father's mrs
smith
ninja gaiden act three
who is it
you must be walter smith the name for
you
i don't care
i don't care if i am i really don't care
it is what it is
look at the got some some tigers
attacking my [ __ ]
oh died i died
[Music]
look at these
i gotta have better timing with that
dude
all right so the crows are gonna be an
issue okay
the crows are gonna be an issue
i get you guys the crows are gonna be an
issue
i can't move on until until i kill the
crow
i can't
go back
can i get a oh these stupid
jeez these crows on my ass they won't
leave
yeah yeah yeah
where's these crows
oh
look at them
look at them
oh
now what is this
what is this
oh he's got a rocket launcher
they try to explain how a ninja's
lasting out a rocket launcher
look at that
yeah get dealt with come here come here
come here do it again encore
ow
ow
it's got a really encore little little
soundtrack though man i'll give it that
it's got a little nice soundtrack got it
got a little bit to it and i see what
they trying to do there
oh what how did i do that
how did i use that ability oh we go with
somewhere now
we going somewhere with life
life might be a little bit more
complete now
ow
oh i died i died
up in b i used up and b like eight times
man it didn't mean it didn't do anything
dude
like it i like the
the uh the little soundtrack they got
going on
come here come here birdie
it's about timing and efficiency
gotta keep it moving guys
we we can't ow
ow
ow these stupid birds
yeah yeah yeah
oh they they they were
they were playing my ass right there man
they were playing me
i need uh i got the timing for that down
i just need to be better at the timing
for it
i don't know what
any of that is
[Music]
look at this thing that thing just moves
right past me i don't got to worry about
that
this thing won't even go down there so
that's not really an issue now i gotta
start worrying about that thing
oh you move
you gotta kill those things
oh
oh
dodge it
get dealt with
i don't got a whole lot of health either
so i'm probably dead
oh it looks like it's another boss
yeah
i'm dead
i ain't making too far in that fight
kidzmu says what is this nonsense
it is
that's it definitely is nonsense kid
i'll have to agree with you on that they
got a dutiful bazooka that somehow isn't
killing me
and uh i'm taking like half my health to
the dude
so uh there's that
but you know what i i did that on
purpose because i wanted i want look i
did that on purpose because i wanted
to be
taken seriously i feel like
you know if i beat the game with like
one hp
you guys can leave me alone
guys can leave me alone man
because then i can say
i'm the very best
that no one ever was
yeah i'm just dodge you
okay
yeah take that
yeah take that too
everyone can get a kid get a shuriken
man
get a shuriken you get a shirt can you
get a shark and everybody gets a shark
yeah get that with
i should be better with
i'd like to get to the boss again al
i could definitely do these a little bit
better i'm not gonna lie
i'm gonna get to the boss of no hp again
didn't even get to the boss but it's all
right man we'll do it again
we'll do it again
still i got this dude with the knife
this dude with the knife there's a
bazooka dude up here gotta dodge him
crotch attack
dodge this one crouch attack
bird
okay okay okay maybe
let me let me
let's try it again
oh
crouch attack
crouch attack
they should give me
like a gold medal for playing this
i feel like i should get like
a medal of honor for playing this game
i should be a stone
with
with a medal of honor the metal gaming
of honor attic played
whatever this ninja gaiden for the nes
let me see when this
yeah i'ma just dodge you i don't even
need to fight you
but i do want to fight you because i
gotta get rid of this bird
if i don't get rid of the bird
they'll come for me
i gotta be better with that
look they got that random they got that
random
out of nowhere lying you ain't seen
those little tigers ever this whole game
and they gonna throw him there at the
last minute so it knocks you off you see
what kind of nonsense you're getting me
playing
god god got me got me messed up man
go ahead and shoot
shoot
kill this bird
see we gotta get this left bird here bam
okay we gotta get it again
encore
okay we gotta kill it again
because i keep resetting the stupid bird
all right all right all right all right
all right i got it man i got it people
breathe with me man
this this
look at that
i can't
i can't hit him but he can hit me like
eight times okay all right
all right i got you i got you i got you
let me let me take a drink
i might need a drink after this game
go ahead and kill me fam kill me there
you go thank you
[Music]
all right all right
let's do this let's do this i got this i
don't but i'm a try
got this dude
just take my time i guess
see i get impatient that's my
that's my achilles heel
i get impatient
i'm have to do that all in one thing
i want
i want all my stuff in one go man
of course
responding
i don't like that responding nonsense
man i think we could deal without that
look at that that dude came out of
nowhere i don't even have to fight that
one all right i gotta turn around
this isn't really much of anything i
just gotta wait for him to turn around
okay
let's have a a weird
yeah okay
gotcha oh my god
is that tiger you have that stupid tiger
oh so he's gonna keep respawning
okay
okay
let me see here man let me see here
let's try this jumpy bouncy dude again
oh okay okay
so how is he doing this okay
so he's throwing random projectiles out
out of nowhere
and he's jumping left to right over and
over again
i only really saw those projectiles on
one side too
to be honest with you guys i only saw
them on one side
only saw them on one side hand fam
side
i'm gonna use that i gotta start like
now trying to make sure that i get
to the end with some health left just so
i can start memorizing that dude's
patterns
oh my god get off
yeah there you go
are you gonna get off this
nothing he's not getting often
that was mad annoying
stupid tiger
let's wait for him to go over there kill
him and go straight in
i don't have a whole lot of health
unfortunately but
you know i think i can move here hit him
a couple times
okay
i got you
okay okay
i can hit the bullets
i see that man
hold up guys
ugh addicts addicted to ninja gaiden hmm
i wouldn't go that far i think you guys
are getting a little bit too
too extra with that
we don't need uh to say i'm addicted to
anything
all right
well a good part of my life trying not
to be addicted to stuff so
i think it's okay to say i'm not
addicted all right there we go
i had to send that out real quick
all right so i got i got to calm down
come on
as long as i'm quick these things aren't
really an issue i just have to be quick
about it
yeah of course
you just got to jump down he's going to
jump across by himself
i don't like the what the controls man
like what's crazy
is we could sit here and we can make fun
of controls on like gta like the older
gta's but god forbid you say older games
have bad
bad
controls because then it's just like
people act like you're being ridiculous
addict you can't make fun of our
controls well that i i tried something
new there i tried something new there it
didn't work out well for me but i tried
something new there
okay
we just dodging you
i ain't even trying to mess with you
wow might as well just jump off at this
point
see i can't even kill myself because of
this grabbing [ __ ]
that's the biggest annoyance is the
grabbing stuff
go from playing something like elder
ring to this
of course of course
i i crouched but somehow i just
completely turned around
i get you man
i get you
i get you
going extra man going extra
oh
i got to take care of this dude
this dude
this dude
jump up here and let him kill himself
let him flip around of course
shoot there we go
oh
wow
oh my god
[Music]
make me appreciate gaming today okay
okay
oh
at least i know i can just
generic look at this man
look how bad the controls are like it's
so hard to clamp off stuff
people's like attic though it's it's the
it's the origins of gaming
you're not a gamer unless you can beat
ninja gaiden
without dying 80 times
addict
of course
i don't like this
oh my god okay okay
[Music]
all right let's do this again
i got i got the the timing right i just
gotta i gotta i gotta pay attention
all right here we
go this little wrestler another wrestler
here
jump down
i don't like
come on
let him flip around
kill him and go in all right so we got a
little decent bit of health on this this
go through
so we want to move over and hit him a
couple times hit him
he's so fast
um
[Music]
boom
[Music]
boom i'm getting hit by that last one
almost every time
okay okay i did better that time i did
better that time
but i got i got him down he's a pretty
simplistic modern boss pattern can i
re-just start the level man
so let's read this chat for a couple
seconds
[Music]
all right so let me see here
all right so i i guess that's the the
name of the individual
let's try to get there of no health loss
i've noticed that they're not really a
big problem
until their attack pattern starts
once their attack pattern starts that's
when like
they become more of an issue than they
really are
dude
[Music]
wow
okay i could have done that one better
uh all right let's do this again
gotcha
the reach he's got is like ridiculous
lost like a good amount of my health
from that
and of course he gets his health back
because that makes sense
come on
i hate the the
i just hate how like
come on
wow
it's it's it's ridiculous
come on
i gotta remember i can hit those bullets
i don't like how that dude just respawns
and i'm still in the area
like
he shouldn't respawn like that i'ma be
real with you
what was that about
[Music]
all right all right
all right all right
see i i'm starting to lose my [ __ ]
come on stupid bird
come on
stupid bird
come on
oh my god
got hit way too many times man way too
many times
oh my god
my back is killing me
uh
i'm already over this guy i'll be right
with you guys
see i'm a big person when it comes to
games by the game being hard not like
the mechanics of the game
and that's why i feel like a lot of
these older games
com their difficulty comes from it's
just the mechanics of the game
it's not really about you know if the
game's actually hard it's just the
mechanics of the game
oh my god
i lose too much health and that [ __ ]
see you can't hit him when
oh my god man
i just got to take my time but
i don't like taking my time man
taking my times whack
see why is this thing coming back
oh great it spawned back because because
it pushed me off
had nothing to do with the difficulty it
just spawned me back
move half an inch somewhere and they're
gonna spawn these things back
i don't even know what the what this
stuff is like don't be real with you
wow
does it on the very first one so i need
to go on the complete right side
all right let's try this again
all right all right these little bazooka
things
come on
see the problem is is they let you
attack things
they they let things
they let a lot of like invincibility
stuff go on where like when you get hit
you can't attack anything so you're
naturally gonna get hit again
why do i always get hit by that i need
to do better on that
all right all right here we go here we
go
[Music]
uh
[Music]
oh my god man
he just like what kind of like pattern
is that just jumping back and forth over
and over again
it's not really a pattern guys i'ma be
real with you
it's not a pattern
i mean i guess it's a pattern but it's a
wack pattern i would roast a game to
have that kind of pattern these days
so you know
i'm starting to learn how to use these
abilities better
[Music]
oh my god
i couldn't even reach a dude
can't hit no one just because you're
invincible kind of nonsense is that
gotcha
come on
oh another one here we go another
opportunity for me to mess up
one
[Music]
oh my god
[Music]
was
man i got about another probably
got an hour this left man
an hour
[Music]
come on
let's go
i don't even know what those are to be
honest with you
see
i
i can't get off
look at all that health i lost because
the gang glitch and i had to unpause i
you have to pause it and unpause it when
that happens there's no way to get off
that my that the side i hate that
clamping on stuff man like it's so
stupid
daddy
[Music]
oh
[Music]
oh my
i'm getting better at fighting
this stuff uh
man it's still annoying
come on
i had all that health
all that health
and i died because he clamped on to the
side
[Music]
what i'm confused what you guys talking
about
oh my god
come play ninja gaiden they said
it's
i don't even have jokes right now that's
how frustrated i am
want to play the most inconsistent game
known to man come play ninja gaiden
at least i'm doing this part better
i just got to do like the rest of the
map better
of course of course
and then the bird stays up on you the
moment it's
the moment that burns up on you it's
literally just gonna keep going around
you like a stupid wasp
i'm going to do a lot better this time
i'm focusing
come on you stupid bird
[Music]
of course
why is there two of them
wow
literally got hit into the zone so it
spawned another one and then
there were two of them coming at me like
that is ridiculous
i was doing so well too man
i got these little green army bands
timing down
stupid bird
oops
[Music]
there we go
come on
all right so
we're good there
except for the random tiger that comes
out of nowhere
[Music]
um
[Music]
like
i'm just starting not to even care to be
honest with you
people were like oh
respect gaming addict
for for this
for this
wow
come on let's go
oh great
could have went worse
come on oh my god
i don't even care i really don't
[Music]
uh at this point man i'm just
just trying
just just playing man i'm getting
frustrated
all right
let's go ahead and set up
of course i got hit once
that doesn't surprise me i feel like my
mic's about to come off my desk again
[Music]
let's go
come on
wow
i mean it could be worse
go there with this much health
it could be worse
i have a little bit of health this time
i gotta just stay on the right side
[Music]
i just don't like the continuous jumping
i don't see a challenge in that because
like it's not really a challenge it's
just like you have to deal with the
mechanics that that is dumb on both
sides
and he doesn't really have a challenging
pattern
like you got to worry about whether or
not your sword is going to connect to
him because of the inconsistency and how
the
the mechanics of the game works if he
hits you one time what ends up happening
is you have that uh that like when
you're invincible and you can't hit
anyone but they can hit you and that can
continue again over and over again
well i thought i was going to get that
one oh well
i need to stop falling for that man
all right all right we got a good amount
a little bit of health here a little bit
of health to work with
i guess
[Music]
[Music]
it's not that he throws the projectiles
if he hits me when he jumps i'm in that
invisible thing so i got to deal with
that i think i just don't like the way
they built games back in the day like
i can i'll eventually beat this whack
dude but
i just don't like
i hate that i took damage off that
[Music]
see look
all right i got
i got to do better when it comes to
these
nothing i could do got stuck on that
ledge he grabbed onto the ledge i should
have waited i keep messing up that was
on me
that one was on me
of course
i don't like that stupid [ __ ] man
sometimes i just feel like the controls
are so unresponsive
i don't know why i've been doing that
wow
about to die here i know that for a frac
i only got like three hp left or some
stuff like that
i wonder if i could jump over those
it's just those left ones because i feel
like
for some reason sometimes like
that bullet will be took out sometimes
it doesn't i don't know
wow
taking damage from something that's not
even on the map anymore
that's that's crazy
all right here we go
so by half my health
we'll see let's get there
[Music]
um
[Music]
dammit
we got somewhere that time man we got
somewhere that time
imma beat him
imma beat him man imma beat him
i think i got him though i think i got
him i just gotta she gotta calm down man
getting annoyed
i don't know what those bags do
out
oh my god if i can get to him with
health that is
come on
let's go
all right all right let's let's do this
let's do this all right
i need to fill those projectiles man
[Music]
don't
[Music]
don't
don't
done took me a little bit but i got him
i got him up out of there
level four stage one
all right all right let's do this let's
do this
[Music]
so
oh my god man
[Music]
i thought those are shurikens i keep
picking up but apparently they're not
i don't know what they are but they're
not shuriken
oh we got the tigers oh the tigers
um yeah see
it's a little unfortunate
very unfortunate
do
wow
[Music]
i feel like i have to get hit by him
all right let's go here
got the
what is that oh it's
barely could see because he's blended in
the screen but yeah people are gonna say
that that that adds on to the challenge
at it
that's one of those things that you know
you just gotta play
i can't realistically jump over him so i
i don't know like do i have to take
damage from him
i ain't feeling that
i don't even know what this does
i guess it's the spin attack
i like that though
oh
oh the fire moves nice
oh those those are those that's a ladder
you know they should probably be a
little bit more uh detailed and you know
something as serious as having a ladder
in the game i'm gonna be real with you
that's that's a little ridiculous i'm
still trying to figure out how to get
past this dude without taking damage
maybe i feel like
i guess that's just about timing in that
end
[Music]
it's about timing i suppose
and i do not have the timing for a dude
with a good machine gun
let me try to like
pull up on him before hitting that
no like
and i feel like if i if i wait on the
timing
what's gonna end up happening
[Music]
[Music]
the xbox twitter account's gone what do
you mean
one second
what's going on
yeah i don't
yeah it looks like the xbox twitter is
gone
wow
i feel like i have to get hit by him man
there's a countdown may want to hit
pause there's a countdown timer
explain to me what you guys mean by a
countdown timer
i i've been playing this this hot
this hot 90s this hotness
i've been playing it
okay so i jump over him all right
wow you can only do that like once
[Music]
upper left
a countdown timer on oh oh you're
talking i thought you talked about like
on xbox or something
i know there's a countdown timer i'm not
really trying to beat the level right
now i'm just trying to learn it better
wow
get hit by some nonsense
i'd rather get hit that
i hate those birds like i really do i
can't stand those birds
all right so we gotta jump on top of
these
let's go up the ladder this time let's
not just jump down like i did last time
and then clearly they they put that one
bird up there to knock me off the whole
damn map
because it because that makes sense
do
that's probably just to kill that one
i'm starting to learn this map better
i love how he can just move his gun
mid
mid punch man mid punt
yeah i'ma just dodgy act like you don't
exist
ow
ow
ow
ow
i don't know what this is but
[Music]
i really really like the uh
the gameplay man the the
oh so we got other ninjas all right
[Music]
dude
[Music]
probably best just to jump over those
besides that one that was literally
deliberately put there to push you off
the map
[Music]
yeah i gotta kill him
[Music]
they both were put there to put them out
[Music]
oh you bet
i mean
i've been getting my ass handed to me
pretty much the whole stream but uh
thank you for being concerned about diaz
thank you man
[Music]
oh my god i'm going to just crouch and
do the best timing i can to get
to get past that part
[Music]
my god
[Music]
gotcha
can you even kill those things man
[Music]
oh yeah just just respawn immediately
after i kill you one time that makes a
lot of sense
[Music]
oh my god they they want me to go over
there and get hit by the dude that's
what they want and it's just i'm not
gonna do it
oh wait he spawns wherever you spawn so
yeah
okay
and i still die but i understand that
that's cool boss that's cool
but you still in here watching my my
lame ass aren't you
[Music]
easy to talk [ __ ] when you just sitting
there in the chat
[Music]
oh now now we got white birds okay
we got white birds
we got white birds
[Music]
white bird
look man i've been popping off this
whole stream
where have you been
i'm getting better at the timing though
up until that one
[Music]
that's a rough timing you have to get
like identical
i don't like that timing that time he's
whack
[Music]
it's not trauma like you guys are just
idiots for i mean i can't i can't blame
you for playing this because it's all
you had
but like this is really the goat that
you guys be talking about this
inconsistency
attacking whatever you like nah man we
ain't going that far
look at this ninja just stalking my ass
oh my god
[Music]
of course random random things
[Music]
i appreciate man you said you'd normally
catch us on the live stream
yeah we oh my god man
lord metroid i ain't getting over
anything i'm allowed to talk however i
want
of course got hit again
got hit again
[Music]
[Music]
oh my god man
[Music]
well clearly i've died a bunch
guys acting like you like the greatest
gamers in the world
probably never even beat this game
[Music]
oh my i hate how the moment you kill
them they come right back
[Music]
all right
it just dodges entirely
gotta be a little bit better
don't want to take too much damage
of course
[Music]
[Music]
oh i know everyone died but people want
to act like they like the greatest
gamers in the world
oh my god
i'm not going for that just jumping
straight over
[Music]
yep going up
[Music]
what's going on here
[Music]
it's probably going to respawn yeah
kind of figure that was going to happen
okay stay down there i don't think
you'll resp
oh my god man
oh so he can probably gotta start
through the whole
thing again
oh no you don't
the music's been pretty good the whole
game to be honest with you
i ain't had no issue with it
it's been solid
gotta get up here fam
wow somehow i didn't jump
oh
[Music]
i guess it is what it is on that one man
[Music]
died like nine times in a row man
yeah it is what it is
i really don't care to be honest with
you
wow
i'm gonna have to like come at him
yeah like that and then get him there
coming out
it is what it is
it's cute that you know what nine euros
do man
[Music]
wow i don't even know if you could jump
in that middle platform
[Music]
why is it not jumping
[Music]
man
look man
i appreciate you guys uh looking out for
us in terms of uh sponsorships but
like the thing is is
they might say they want sponsorships
but they probably want you know i don't
know exactly what their parameters are
do
okay
oh what is this
spinny jajitsu tarzan i don't know oh
he's gonna come down here and hit me
oh that thing's got that
oh i knew i was dead there
no i was pressing the button we go here
act like i wasn't lord metroid
it's the inconsistency man we're going
that's what i'm sticking with
oh my god man
[Music]
i guess starting the mission over again
i mean it's not like it was like
hard to get to that point again
[Music]
come on shoot
i need to stop going for that they put
that deliberately there so you'll go for
it you'll get killed immediately
[Music]
come on man like seriously
[Music]
did
then i'll go for
oh what the hell was that
oh my god
okay
oh my
dude that's just ridiculous
what am i supposed to hit him with
and it feels like none of these
projectiles i'm getting are working
i keep getting projectiles and they're
not working
[Music]
like why aren't they working they were
working a couple minutes ago
stop oh my god i hate this stupid game
he's probably going to respawn you know
oh my god
it's like half my health from that dude
now what's this oh two of them okay
i appreciate fighting two of them
you know i thought one of them was gonna
be difficult two of them
you know i i i was jealous of myself for
only being able to fight one
enemy so let's let's fight two i got you
guys let's fight two
you know two
felt like
you know me fighting one
would have been too easy
oh my god
[Music]
fighting two at once
[Music]
on some nonsense
the ninja stars wasn't working
we brought you those ninja stars was
useless they was not working
i
i pressed the button man i pressed it
i feel like the inconsistency is just
ridiculous
like there's like a a millisecond of a
lag
see they're not
these ninja stars are
working
oh great
so
playing it on the nintendo switch
probably my issue playing this stuff on
this nonsense console
oh you can fall off okay
i'd rather you fall off it makes things
a little bit easier
that's cool man beat it when you're nine
years old like you ain't gonna get on my
nerves saying that you beat something
wow i pressed the wrong button
meant to press x but i pressed b that
was that was my mess up
[Music]
okay
don't work the way you're supposed to
okay
i really can't stand this game
i might i really can't stand this game
no i'ma blame that blame anything i want
lord metro i blame i blame you you
frustrated me in the chat so that's
what's that's what's causing me to die
so much there you go
how you like them apples buddy
how you like them apples buddy
oh great
i don't like the way that be going
sometimes man
will you talk
no
i definitely won't be talking about this
game
during sunday i'm gonna plead the fifth
i'm gonna plead the fifth just because
you guys want me to talk about this game
and i refuse to uh
to to let you guys win man
and unfortunately for you guys you guys
got about six more minutes of this game
and then the entertainment's over
and i go back to my life
the recoil is just ridiculous
the the recoil is just atrocious
and then not to mention half the time i
press the jump button
my dude's like oh you're trying to jump
no we don't do that here fam
we don't jump
we don't jump fam we don't do that here
oh my god
these things are the most annoying
things to fight in this game
the little spinning jar jitsu
white
ninjas or whatever you want to call
them i would get up and try to do what
they're doing but i would i would i
would i would kiss the floor man
they they doing stuff with their body
that i couldn't do
i can't do that
it's not happening
oh that's cool you ain't never use those
till now
look at him shooting
not happening buddy
buddy
i gotta find a better way of doing this
because i know that dude doesn't jump
down here
i lose so much health trying to get to
this part
oh my god
that's fine
nobody write anything this you have to
collect these in order to i don't care
about no ninjutsu stuff man here in
about five minutes
it's a wrap for this game i will never
grace this game with my presence ever
again
well
if this dude keeps spamming someone get
him up out of there
that that's your warning fam
no spamming
especially not
especially not this damn game
[Music]
come on
you only do it like once or twice like
i feel like
how
oh my god
what i had to jump to that there i'm
done i'm just done with this game
[Music]
you guys are gonna have to you guys
gonna probably throw some super chats in
that chat before i continue playing this
stuff man
give me ten dollars with the super chats
i'll play it for another hour well
that's that's too much all right we wait
okay i don't think 10
nah we ain't doing that don't don't
throw nothing in there actually never
mind never mind i actually want to uh to
get stuff done
we ate we we
the house is closed
and i keep getting
i might as just restart i might as well
just restart
[Music]
because i'm getting i'm getting
destroyed i'm getting destroyed
oh my gosh man
i just don't like like the way the game
sets up like it gets on my nerves
not gonna lie
i'm only on level four
how many levels are in the game
how many levels are in the game
i love how i can do that one
oh don't bother with the others it's not
that it's hard it's just it's
it's the mechanics i'm not fighting the
the difficulty of game i'm fighting the
mechanics
i don't understand why it's so
inconsistent when this stuff wants to
work
there's only five there's eight and i'm
on i'm halfway through the game and you
guys gonna guys gotta run your mouth
i got hit there unfortunately
okay
let's do can move
wow
the ninja stars won't work i don't
understand how many times i have to tell
you guys that if they don't work i
pressed them just fine
the only ones that work is those fire
ones
[Music]
okay just go ahead and fall down so i
can take one hit from you
rather take one hit from you than deal
with these mechanics to jump up and down
because they're they're horrible
i don't know what to do with the blue
things like you guys keep talking about
the blue things i
i lose so much health this part right
here
all right
of course i couldn't do nothing i had to
be quicker
[Music]
no
a minute ago it wasn't i'm telling you
guys listen
this game glitches and you have to press
start to unglitch it i've showed you
guys me being stuck on walls and until i
press start it wouldn't let me jump off
the wall
so
that's all i'm saying man like it's not
as simple as you guys say
[Music]
and then i just died there for no reason
i'm gonna give this
five more tries and then
and then it's a wrap for uh
for whatever this game is called
it's a
wrap five more try five more good tries
of course
wow
[Music]
wow now i'm dead
see
pushing the button won't come off press
start
unstarted
does it
[Music]
do
[Music]
it's not game breaking but it glitches
on stuff when i do stuff
that's not game breaking i don't know
what is
not game breaking
it's not game breaking at it
it's all
it's off
it's all
it's all flowers and sunshine sunshine
ow
owl
it's all flowers and sunshine
sun shines man sun shines someone get
that that dude up out of there someone
someone
hide him
because he he's literally here just the
troll and i'm not trying to deal with
that right now
oh
do you have to like hit them in their
back to do damage
i'm kind of curious on that
why don't you actually move man
[Music]
oh i thought you would just spam me
something over and over again man hit
the cameras to collect these the symbols
under the timer on the top of your
screen these are points that your ninja
starts use i thought you were just
strolling me man
oh that's like with a second try
do
that
wow
it literally just
that was unfortunate
[Music]
oh my god
[Music]
oh jw is a chef
man this game brings back memories beat
them all back when games were hard young
man
hard oh my god
the hard nonsense again j dub is a shell
look
does it got some difficulty to it yes
but i think the difficulty is more about
what the game wants you to do not
necessarily about the difficulty itself
but it is a difficult game i i just
okay i got a lot of health give me a
minute i gotta really concentrate on
this
wow
[Music]
sitting there getting too comfortable
playing man
i'm old now addict yeah i'm definitely
getting up there in age
i'm not old as some people man but i'm
definitely
getting there
i'm not going for that it's just getting
me hurt
do
do
[Music]
i'm trying to save my upgrades and stuff
for the boss
[Music]
i don't see the point in using them if i
can effectively get past it
because every besides like this little
aspect up here
because i think the consistency is too
much
it i don't have enough consistency to
get up here
like without having uh like serious
issues
he's feeling it stop that nonsense this
is the third try
third try
third try man
get off of that man
oh my god i don't like how it just grabs
onto walls and it's so hard to get off
of them
[Music]
it's it's whack i'm not gonna lie to you
guys man it's wack
of course
yeah yeah yeah
it's not that i'm jumping at the wall
they're hitting me into the wall and
it's and it's making me stuck on the
wall
like you should have to like grab one of
the wall or something or at least like
hold the
the button on the wall it should just
magically put you on the wall
oh my god
[Music]
appreciate her for coming by though
i don't know what those things do
of course
of course
homeboy just pushes me off
[Music]
so
get off the wall
see
it's not using the star
[Music]
thank you
i'm telling you there's some kind of
glitch that happens where i can't use
anything
oh my god
i'm not playing ghost and goblins i
don't even know what that is but i'm not
playing it
[Music]
i'm really just this is my last attempt
i'm just not gonna keep bugging myself
with this [ __ ] man
i've i've obligated my
for this game
you know it and see look at that like
that i'm like i mean you could you could
argue i'm the one playing i literally
showed you me pressing the button it
wouldn't come off
but the moment i
[Music]
it's not me it's not about ninjutsu
what i when i had the the dagger thing
it wasn't working sometimes when i get
stuck on the sides it doesn't do
anything unless i
oh my god
the controls are just so inconsistent
i can use the d-pad
[Music]
oh you can use the d-pad
[Music]
do
of course
now i'm having an issue
getting over there
taking hot almost all my health
oh i i'm starting to get too annoyed
guys i i'm a
after this one it's it's a wrap
i played it for about two and a half
hours
that's that's that's all i'm obligated
for
wasn't even obligated for that but
foreign
thank you
um
oh my god
get off the wall
get off the damn wall
[Music]
is a lot better to this game is a lot
easier when i'm using the d-pad
i feel like it's like less mess-ups
so
[Music]
[Music]
oh my god
all right you guys
this is the last try like i'm just
i'm getting too frustrated i'm not even
enjoying it anymore
[Music]
i'm really frustrated with myself that
this whole game i've been
oh
oh my god
okay just don't use the ability
yeah i'm done man i'm done
i might i'm gonna fight them one more
time but it's just
[Music]
oh my god
i don't understand how to damage these
things like i feel like you have to hit
uh you have to hit behind them but then
when i behind them
there's nothing like it really doesn't
do anything either so
i i wasn't doing any damage to him
[Music]
i mean
of course i got hit by that
um
oh that time i was doing better
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
oh my god
do
um
oh my god man
[Music]
[Music]
do
do
oh okay here we go here we go
oh wait
[Music]
i don't know how it fell off
[Music]
see that that's the [ __ ] that frustrates
me
is like how unresponsive the controller
can be sometimes
[Music]
do
do
do
oh
okay
hmm
[Music]
oh my god
[Music]
do
so
see i'm starting to mess up too much
do
do
oh my god
[Music]
get off it
nothing
the moment i get off it lets me jump off
you guys can say what you want there's
some kind of glitch
i don't care what you guys got to say
come on guys
i wonder if like you kill them
individually or something
oh my god
[Music]
i mean you guys can say what you want
i'm the one dealing with it
i've literally showed you guys be
stuck on a wall and me pressing the
button to get off the wall and it's not
getting off the wall but the moment i
press start and press the same button it
gets off the wall
so yeah i don't know what to tell you
about that it feels like you know if you
don't want to listen to proof that's not
my fault
oh my god
at least i got like the stage pretty
much down i don't really have any
problem with the stage anymore
i just gotta master how to take out this
boss
[Music]
of course
push me up push me
sometimes i had to use the analog stick
because i'm just so used to it by now
[Music]
like doing like doing this is easier
with the uh
the d-pad but when i go up stuff like
this
it's easier for me to use the analog
stick
i'm about to have to reset the whole map
again
[Music]
that's usually how it goes i don't know
why it's been different here lately
all right let's see here
i need to stop jumping i'm just getting
myself killed
oh he glitched through that you guys saw
that
look at that man you guys like stay
under the pill attic stay under the
pillow i stayed under the pillow they
still hit me under that bill
[Music]
oh my god man i just
the biggest thing i don't like is the
automatic clamping that's the biggest
thing that just annoys me
do
do
do
all right
why is there only one now
do i glit did i do something wrong
or was there only one that was that
could take damage this whole time
[Music]
[Music]
oh jw is a show this is why games the
80s and 90s were the hardest just
slightly more
move back when they are near the columns
and jump
[Music]
i don't like these things spawning
oh i'm good
[Music]
come on
oh my god
all right i think i'm done man
i'm done i got the
the stage five i don't know how many
stages is in this game but i got to
stage five man i got to stage five
oh so there's only one more stage after
this
all right i'll give this 13 more minutes
let's see what happens
see if i get some progress
no it's not that i'm a quitter dude i
just i got other stuff to do
i've been streaming for almost three
hours like what else do you want from me
quitter
guys want more more from me man
man this dude's annoying
man
you guys going to put more super chats
in there man because uh that's the only
way i'm staying on this stuff
i had to feel like i
i'm being valued for my entertainment oh
my god
that green ninja came out of nowhere
[Music]
oh my god
what did i get myself into with this you
know i i could
i could have
been doing so much more between now and
then what's this dude like
come on
just
birds
birds man
let's not even make like realistic
upgrades of birds let's just make one
white
that's what we're gonna do we're just
gonna make it white
it's gonna do the exact same thing we're
just gonna put some dumb stuff in here
like this thing
come on come on you stupid bird yeah
take that l
youtube ninja
this thing's mad annoying
yeah fall off the map how did you
respond
[Music]
how did that
they let that thing respond
that is
that is golden
they they are killer dubs like i mean
ain't goes here and try to front that
i apologize lately about to end the
stream here in a couple minutes
about to end the stream man
and then i fall off
fall off immediately
like the idiot i am
i have to get something to eat too i
have an eight today
come on man
this thing's annoying can i hit that no
that thing's annoying man
that's the only issue i've seem to have
had on this map is
is that thing i'm not to like throw a
boomerang at him or something
so
oh
only got one hp left
that's unfortunate
oh my god
[Music]
uh
[Music]
so
oh my god
how to deal with those people throwing
stuff upstairs
oh my god
all right man i i'm done i appreciate
everyone for coming through
um i need to get some food i'm hungry uh
and i've been streaming this for a
minute so i'm i'm done with the stream
see how long i've been streaming
i have been streaming
for two hours
and 55 minutes
that is
a few more that i was going to give you
guys before then
uh you know i i appreciate it you got
guys pulled up man there's a few of you
that was in here throughout the night
uh i appreciate it you know let's do a
pre-show real quick hold up hold up
let's do a pre-show
all right
so
the game was fun i can't say it wasn't
fun it was definitely a fun moment
and you know once i started playing the
game more and more i started like
learning the timing and stuff better i
know i could beat the game it's just i
don't want to play the game i'll be real
with you but it was a fun experience i
can't say it was like a horrible
experience especially the bosses i think
i was enjoying the bosses in this game
more than anything else because i really
enjoy
bosses and these uh in any type of game
like i like patterns uh that's something
i really enjoy uh phase 114 is this
every friday
look
we'll have to find a way to
to do like a
a reward thing
uh i don't know if i'll stream every
friday maybe you know it's a
an every week
by thing now i don't know if i'll be
streaming this game
uh or these older games because
you guys see uh
i'm struggling man struggling a little
bit you know just a little bit just a
little bit but it was definitely a fun
experience
i feel like that should give him a few
pointers though okay i'd like to see
you know
you know what we need to see man
we need to see
cognito king and solve streaming this
that's what i want to see
i want to see all this all this
this this extraness they always be doing
on me on iop i want to see them coming
here and beat this like it ain't nothing
that's what i want to see
we need
lord cognito
or king david or sovereign one of these
individuals need to come up here and
show the young wolf how it's done i got
to act five
and that's where i think i you know i
could easily you said there's one more
act um i think i could have easily have
done that that act if if i would have
kept playing you know
i maybe i'll restream this i don't know
it's it's like i said man
we'll see how how
how how supportive the community is you
know how how much they want to see
because obviously i ain't gonna waste my
time if not a lot of people see it gotta
have the majority of people i'll owe you
guys three more streams uh i owe the
shinobi i'm pretty sure next week
and then the friday after that i have to
play battletoads so you know i owe you
guys two more streams after
this king probably could do it yeah i
king definitely could you know they've
played these games that they remember a
lot of them more i was coming into all
that that's the blind like straight up
blind i was coming to all of it blind so
you know i feel like if i had a little
bit more time to it it would have been
doing
that
oh don't talk of a bee about it see
here's the thing
i'm going
into i'm going into this with no
experience in these type of games at all
i'm sure playing a lot of these older
games the the experience of playing
these older games would help you
carrying over to the newer to
another game like sure shinobi and maybe
the uh ninja gaiden are different games
but
playing those and having the timing and
learning the timing of individual games
probably help you with other games uh
you know it's obviously it's it's not
like rock for rock or apples
to apples judging apples it's you know
it's different experiences but i'm
pretty sure that experience can carry
over to the newer ones if that makes
sense to you guys
but you know it was um
it was definitely a fun experience i
can't say i didn't enjoy playing it i
enjoyed it i enjoyed the bosses the most
the bosses were pretty fun especially
the the one with the two pillars that
was a unique experience i i was throwing
those
stars over and over again i was trying
to i didn't know you could get rid of
one of them that was interesting you can
get rid of one of them i i don't know if
it's they share equal health of that bar
or
one is an illusion and the other one
isn't
so i don't know exactly how that goes
now i got to play shinobi next week
friday
at 5 00 pm i got to play shinobi maybe
i'll do it at six i don't know but i
gotta play shinobi next week at five to
six pm
and then after that then we'll go from
there we'll see what's next oh well no
then i gotta play battle toads
then and then you know we might do
another another little uh
go for attic to play some old [ __ ] i
don't know if it'll be maybe not
necessarily old stuff every time but it
was a fun experience i got more a little
bit more respect for uh for for this
game a little bit more just a little bit
more
uh
i
there for a little bit for a good 10 15
20 minutes
i was
i was definitely
getting frustrated and letting my uh
annoyance take over
so you know that was on me i should have
did better on that
that was on me guys
oh let me see
if i got any messages
all right so
looking at this now
what final thing you played
you play first what final fantasy game i
i can't remember
it might have been eight i don't know it
was so long ago
i can't remember which ones was which
which ones did you guys play first
i can't it might have been one of the
original final fantasies i don't know
like
i think the first like real really good
memory for final fantasy was eight like
i remember like the the scene where
you're
going in that war at the beginning of
the game that was a really um you know
memorable experience that i had
i called my mom into buying final
fantasy viii so
you know it was um it was a it was a fun
experience man and i appreciate everyone
for coming through you know liking that
button we got 30 people in here man like
that i like that man like that
you kept your word and gave a game a
good go thanks for a great stream
i tried man i tried uh someone said what
shinobi i don't know i don't know which
schnoby i'm just i just play what i'm
told i just play what i'm told
so you know i don't know which stream
you guys gonna have to uh miss me on
that
uh i i'll probably talk about my
experience with this game on iop i don't
know yet i don't know yet we'll see
we'll see
next week is shinobi i don't know what
shinobi i know it's on the xbox i'm
pretty sure they said it's a backwards
compatible game on the xbox
so you will have to see and go from
there
but i appreciate it for coming through
man we uh we're going to end the stream
you know i'm pretty sure we're about to
come up on
two year marks for some of the members i
put
a special thing as the two year mark
that shows up i just don't know if it's
going to show up now shinobi 3's the
genesis version jam they was on shinobi
three
that's crazy
i don't know it's on the first it's on
the uh the xbox that's all i know it's
on the xbox
that's all i know
that's all i know
on the first xbox man but i appreciate
everyone come through i'm gonna get
something to eat you know i i gotta play
that i'm gonna play some more elden ring
i'll get a little bit more i'm gonna
make some content for you guys on the
channel when it comes to eldon ring
so keep a look out for that but until
next time man you guys have a good day